你好, You miss a zoo by any chance.。
我的名字是Zoom out。
你叫Zoom out?。
你有个意识吗？
能帮我们看看你的意识吗？
唯有有谁在吗？
其实我继续是享受.。
对不起， 再送再次吧.。
呃...
我還記得媽媽
OK Sir, I'm arresting you on suspicion of rape, OK?。
because it is alleged that on the 14th of November last year。
you have vaginally raped a female at this address, OK?。
you do not have to say anything, but it may harm your defence。
if you do not mention one question, something which you later allow and call。
anything you do say may be given in evidence。
your arrest is necessary for a prompt and effective investigation, OK?。
let me finish, your time of arrest is now 153。
come on, come out so I can check people。
or allow something cover here。
can I have a jug here or anything?。
yeah, we'll get that to you, shuffle it out。
shuffle it out。
yeah, please。
我們在前面聽到的錄音。
就是來自於2024年1月24日的1點53分。
倫敦警方逮捕鄒正豪使。
使用的現場執法記錄遺中的錄像。
視頻中的警方在跟鄒正豪。
確認完他的個人信息及ID後。
就把他當場逮捕
逮捕原因是一位女性向警方報案。
稱鄒正豪曾在2023年11月14日。
在他位於向保的公寓裏。
強姦過他
也正是因為這位女性的勇敢。
鄒正豪至少長達3年對女性的心情。
才終於得意結束
但出人意料的是警方在仔細調查完。
鄒正豪案件之後發現。
他並不是第一個向警方報案的人。
早在2023年5月。
就有一位受害者向警方提出了指控。
可惜在當時的報警過程中。
因為翻譯等原因被擱置。
在2024年1月成功逮捕鄒正豪之後。
隨著更多的公開信息報道出來。
越來越多的鄒正豪案中的受害者。
也陸續站出來指控鄒正豪的強姦罪行。
根據公開的判決信息顯示。
鄒正豪案中已知的受害者至少有10人。
其中3人在倫敦受害。
7人在中國受害
此外
信息中還表示
根據鄒正豪在信心中拍攝的視頻證據推斷。
如果再加上身份不明的受害者數量。
最終的數字可能會到50到60位。
受害者全部都是中國女性。
沒有例外
在鄒正豪案判決結束後。
更多認識她的
曾經受到過侵犯的女孩們相互鼓勵。
又有23位女性開始向警方指控。
鄒正豪的性侵罪行。
此時我們再回頭看。
開頭提到的那位勇敢的女性。
她不是第一個
也不是最後一個
鄒正豪
一個我們可能到現在為止。
大多數人都比較熟悉的名字。
當然大家現在對她的低印象。
也都是性侵犯懦夫。
但如果時間我們倒推到案發前。
她真的有表現出來。
任何一丁點像是性侵犯。
值得我們警惕的樣子嗎。
鄒正豪是1997年生人。
可能比我們大多數聽眾年紀都要更小。
根據一家媒體報導。
鄒正豪家境相對富裕。
附近是東莞松山湖。
高薪技術產業開發區。
相關公司的董事及黨委。
可以說是從小就沒有缺過錢。
本科在廣東工業大學。
讀的是二加二
也就是本科的兩年在國內。
兩年在國外
2017年開始她搬到英國生活。
在北愛爾蘭的貝爾法斯特女王大學。
攻讀機械工程學位。
又過了兩年進入倫敦大學。
簡稱是UCL
攻讀機械工程碩士學位。
截止到被逮捕期間。
鄒正豪已經開始繼續在UCL。
攻讀同專業的博士學位。
打開她的社交賬號。
你可以看到她幾乎是一身的設置品牌。
手腕的勞力士手錶。
LV的外套
還有她半裸的上身。
引以為傲的身材
年輕
帥氣
有錢
高學歷
這或許是很多人對她的低印象。
然而
但凡你在試圖了解她一點。
接近她真實的社交圈。
你還會聽到更多不一樣的評價。
有人說
她們一起聚餐點外賣的時候。
鄒正豪很摳門
不會A自己的那份錢。
有人說
她的那些設置品
其實都是假貨
打造富二代人設罷了。
也有人說
她
好像有信任
她會經常在朋友面前。
炫耀自己的性能力。
以及
性經驗
她說自己睡過100個以上的女人。
對她們很好
很大方
送過很多昂貴的禮物。
她熱愛社交
她租房時發布的帖子就說。
要隔音好的公寓
因為有社交需求
會想搞轟趴
也希望社友是喜歡社交的人。
以上關於鄒正豪的討論當中。
我們得以拼湊出一個。
稍微有些模糊
有複雜的形象
你可能會說
人本來
就都是複雜的嘛？
有很多面也很正常。
可能你身邊
就有這樣類似的人。
完事不公
暗幕虛榮
將女性看作是性資源。
並且以此
作為自己獲得成就感的來源。
那如果再來聽一聽。
親自跟鄒正豪
見過面的女生的評價。
你會怎麼想
她們說
鄒正豪調的酒很濃。
本來酒量很好
但不知道為什麼
喝過她調的幾杯酒之後。
就很容易變得
不醒人士
她們說
鄒正豪不喜歡在公共場所約會。
一直會邀請她們
到她的家裡做作
她們還說
鄒正豪總是喜歡不經過允許。
強行親吻
甚至意圖發生性關係。
將這些女性的話
結合到之前對
鄒正豪的評價當中。
你會發現
這就是完整
清晰的一條
犯罪鏈條
鄒正豪通過
打造自己的形象和人設。
來加強自己的信息引力。
隨後再使用
社交軟件
或者是朋友介紹組局。
或者是派對
來跟異性建立聯繫。
等到對方同意見面。
或者約會之後
再把對方約老自己的家裡。
在酒裡進行下藥
最後完成避兼
我們這麼聽
可能會有人覺得
誰會上當呢？
對吧？
但這恰恰就是美食美客。
可能發生在我們身邊。
真實的故事
小燕是一位
剛到倫敦求學的
普通大學生
剛認識鄒正豪的時候。
他會把自己描述為一個學霸。
他會在自己的賬號上。
發佈一些正在學習的照片。
也會聊關於自己的理想。
比如
刻骨讀書
在學術上取得更高的成就。
小燕覺得
他雖然家境優惡
但並沒有那種傲慢的氣質。
恰恰相反
他謙遜
他乖巧
是一個為夢想
一直在腳踏實地努力的人。
就這樣
2023年5月
小燕答應了鄒正豪的邀請。
去到他家裡
不惜功課
小燕覺得
倫敦大學博士再讀的鄒正豪。
能夠給他很多學習上的幫助。
結果也顯然如此
鄒正豪非但沒有不耐煩。
甚至還會耐心地
跟他討論數學上的問題。
而且在這次見面的過程當中。
鄒正豪並沒有做出。
任何讓小燕感到不適的行為。
他總是能夠
將分寸拿捏的恰到好處。
以至於結束之後
讓小燕覺得相處下來。
甚至是很舒服
有邊界感
嗯
又過了一段時間
鄒正豪跟小燕說
他能準備半個派對。
幾個朋友一起聚聚。
希望他能夠一起過來。
那既然是派對
就免不了要喝酒嗎。
還是在一個不太熟的。
男性朋友家裡
小燕就考慮了一段時間。
最後想到
鄒正豪
接觸下來算是比較身世的類型。
應該不會做什麼壞事。
也就答應去了
那為了保險己見呢？
小燕還叫上了
另一個自己的朋友。
結伴參加
那他叫一個朋友
還是能相互照應一下。
對保護自己的安全。
嗯
那儘管
之前做過一些思想準備。
但還是沒想到
派對氛圍下的鄒正豪。
簡直跟那天
一起學習的狀態
兩模兩樣
他能很會勸酒
不停的讓小燕喝下一杯。
又一杯的烈酒
好像人很煩這種
勸酒的是吧？
平時自認為酒量不錯的小燕。
很快就醉了
小燕知道
這不是自己平時該有的樣子。
因為一般喝到一定程度。
都會先經歷那種
情緒高障
興奮的過程
才會趨近於
意識模糊的狀態嗎。
結果那天呢？
小燕只知道自己從某一刻開始。
就變得有些昏昏沉沉的。
他意識到
自己不能在陌生的男性家裏。
就此暈倒過夜
於是
小燕開始想要回家。
但鄒正豪此時又開始。
打引號的體貼的說。
那你這會頭這麼暈的話。
建議先躺下來休息一會。
等稍微好一點了再走。
不然他也不放心
於是
小燕就被鄒正豪
辦餐服
辦強制性的
帶到了自己的臥室裏。
此時的小燕
想說話
但說不清楚
已經開始無法
親切的表達自己的意願。
但他記得
他的朋友也在呀？
小燕呢就強打清醒的。
讓朋友帶自己回家。
但小燕的朋友
卻被鄒正豪
堵在了臥室門口
鄒正豪以一貫
乖巧
紳士的語氣說
小燕這會兒
罪得太厲害了
走都走不動
你就算想帶小燕回家。
可能也拖不動他呀？
不如
就讓他在這兒休息一會吧？
在這兒待著
反而更安全
此時的小燕在臥室裏。
聽的疫情而出
他想大聲叫他朋友過來。
但他做不到
小燕的朋友離開後。
鄒正豪又端著一杯飲料過來。
讓小燕繼續喝下去。
於是同時
鄒正豪也打開了攝像機。
開始拍攝小燕的狀態。
臥室內的鄒正豪
也跟客廳的鄒正豪。
完全盼住兩人
紳士變成了暴君
鄒正豪觀察完後
似乎並不滿意小燕現在的狀態。
於是他開始不停的責備小燕。
說他浪費了他的酒。
一杯又一杯
繼續灌到小燕的嘴裏。
此時的小燕
意識到自己
處在一個十分危險的狀態。
腎上腺素和求生本能。
讓小燕站了起來
走向臥室的門
他說
我要離開
但鄒正豪卻開始用滿力。
一次又一次的將小燕推倒。
用力的暗注小燕
不讓他離開臥室
鄒正豪向小燕保證。
自己絕對不會動他。
讓他不要再掙扎了。
小燕想走
但被壓住了雙手
根本動都動不了
他開始尖叫
開始哭泣
開始求救
直到自己開始失去意識。
這是小燕在鄒正豪的臥室裏。
為數不多的記憶
當他再次醒來的時候。
發現自己身上的衣服。
已經不見了
取而代之的是
同樣裸體的鄒正豪。
此時的小燕
幾乎失去了所有直覺。
但他知道
此時的鄒正豪在幹嘛？
他看到鄒正豪的眼神。
他的表情
甚至還有鄒正豪手裏。
拿著的攝像機
等到小燕
再一次恢復意識的時候。
已經是第二天的上午。
他在穿衣服的時候。
發現自己的內衣
已經不見了
他不知道自己
應該如何對待
躺在旁邊的鄒正豪。
只能逃命時的離開。
經過了這一天
小燕想了很久
自己是不是做錯了什麼。
是不是答應別人
去家裏喝酒
本身就是一件錯誤的事情。
但他知道
有一件事
絕對是已經發生的。
那就是
鄒正豪強姦了自己。
小燕知道姓同意
是怎麼一回事
而昨晚發生的一切。
絕對稱不上是一次。
你請我願下發生的性行為。
想到這裏
小燕就開始向
倫敦都會警察報警。
但他出來找到
他並不熟悉這裏的法律。
再加上警方
本身缺乏完備的
翻譯服務
以及心裏輔導
讓遭受了
精神創傷的小燕
感到了巨大的挫敗感。
導致最後沒有辦法。
繼續追溯
最終只能通過
發佈小紅書筆記的方式。
來提醒
其他在英國的女性。
提防鄒正豪這個人。
雖小燕就是23年報警了。
但是因為翻譯問題。
沒有成功立案的那個女生。
對的
也可以說
她就是
鄒正豪連環性侵案中的。
吹哨人
大家常說
遭受過性侵害的人。
就像是一座孤島
因為他們會內疚
他們會自責
他們會時常責怪和反思。
是不是自己哪裏沒做好。
才讓這些性侵者
有了可撐之機
讓這些性侵者認為。
就是經過自己
性同意後的性行為。
如果自己當天沒有復約。
結局
會不會不一樣
同時他們也害怕
如果被家人
朋友知道了這件事情之後。
會不會對自己
有其他的看法
所以他們會藏
把這件事情當作一個祕密。
默默的埋在心裏
直到自己變成一座孤島。
事實上
不光他們自己會這麼想。
就連旁觀者也會這麼想。
在小燕的小文書筆記評論下。
一開始
還有很多同情
和鼓勵的朋友
為他打氣
但慢慢的流量持變大後。
更多不一樣的聲音。
就開始出現
他們責怪小燕
當初為什麼要去男生家裏。
為什麼要喝那麼多。
一擊
為什麼不保護好自己。
小燕
在如潮水般有來的責罵生中。
開始有了溺水的感覺。
直到另一隻手伸向了他。
等到小燕順著手臂的方向。
望過去之後
他發現
那是一隻
來自另一座孤島的手。
此時
兩座孤島彼此相連。
他們雙方開始相互鼓勵。
他們讓對方知道
自己並不是這個世界上。
唯一一個如此無助的人。
2025年1月
在倫敦刑事法庭
對鄒振豪的審判
正式開庭
小燕和他
成為了協助給鄒振豪定罪的。
唯二兩名女性
在庭上
法院展示了
逮捕鄒振豪後
搜查到的相關證據。
其中
包含大量的非法藥物。
毒品
隱藏式攝像頭
各種電子設備
性侵受害者的私人物品。
以及6.5TB的影像資料。
時長總共超過
1660個小時
視頻調數總共
超過1270條
其中直接設計到
強姦的就有58條。
當然在庭上放映的。
也包含鄒振豪
並請小燕視的視頻。
令當時所有在場的人。
感到恐懼的是
在這些影像資料裡。
還有一張照片
照片內容並不是拍攝的。
裸露的身體
而是一張鄒振豪
環抱著熟睡的小燕的自拍。
在不知行的人眼裡看起來。
甚至
會誤認為是情侶一般。
鄒振豪在辯護中提出。
自己雖然受到過良好的教育。
但是在性教育的領域。
是缺失的
它是因為受到時間停止。
類型題材的色情作品影響。
再加上自己患有失眠症。
所以才會在這方面。
產生特殊的性疲
它的辯護律師
同樣也以這個作為出發點。
為鄒振豪的犯罪行為。
進行辯護
說如此高學歷
高智慧
只是因為一些不好的念頭。
而侮辱其圖
他還這麼年輕
以他的聰明才智
如果接受好的引導。
未來就還有改造的機會。
以此來希望減輕刑法。
當時負責本案的女性法官。
並沒有採納這位辯護律師的想法。
他認為
鄒振豪正式所謂的聰明才智。
才讓他能夠進行策劃。
實施對一個又一個女性的性侵。
再結合她特殊的性癖。
和喪屍人性的性侵手法。
反而更是加強了他未來對於社會。
以及其他女性的危險性。
因此
出於為公眾提供足夠保護的考量。
對鄒振豪的定罪
需要進行定格判法。
最終刑期確認為
無期徒刑
聽到這裡
你可能會常說一口氣。
把強姦犯生之以法。
接大歡喜
並且還判刑那麼重。
有可能
鄒振豪就會在監獄裡面。
待一輩子
在這之後
應該不會再有任何人。
敢再這麼肆無忌憚的。
對女性實施性侵了吧？
起碼
在這片土地上的
中國男性
不敢這麼做了吧？
但是
如果你2025年在倫敦生活。
3月份鄒振豪
被判處無期徒刑
在這之後的
不到三個月的時間裏。
另一起幾乎一模一樣的犯罪。
還在繼續發生
徐超
今年33歲
2013年來到英國。
在格林威治大學
攻讀碩士學位的時候。
他就發現了一個商機。
什麼商機
那就是
中國留學生畢業後。
想要找工作
或者說留在英國
比較困難
那大多數人
就苦於沒有合適的方式和渠道。
再有就是簽證問題。
於是
碩士畢業後
徐超就和其他幾位朋友。
一起創辦了一家招聘公司。
那徐超就作為合夥人和高管。
一方面對接英國的公司企業。
另一方面對接廣大的。
中國留學生
那從對他簡短的工作描述中。
大家應該也能知道。
徐超在日常生活裏。
所主要接觸的
幾乎都是出入社會。
甚至是
還沒有怎麼
踏入到社會上的年輕人。
也因此
大家對他的印象中。
他一直都是一個
大哥哥形象的角色。
小雪第一次接觸到徐超的場所。
是在他的大學裏
既然主要客戶
是在英國留學的學生。
那徐超平日裏
最主要的一項工作內容。
就是去到各種大學裏。
舉辦各種各樣的
面向華人的
職業招聘會了
不知道你當時
有沒有類似這樣的活動會。
也是有的
也算是比較常見
那因為小雪
是有畢業後留在英國的想法的。
想要知道在英國求職的。
相關情報和信息
所以自然也就去參加了。
那在這個活動結束後。
小雪就跟其他幾個朋友。
一起在路上
又偶然碰到了徐超。
其中一位朋友就說。
想要咨詢一下
畢業後找工作的一些問題。
問問看徐超他們公司。
能夠提供一些什麼樣的幫助。
或者說是機會
於是徐超就表示
可以直接到公司免費給他們。
做一些咨詢建議
那本著想要在英國找工作的想法。
小雪就跟朋友一起。
來到了徐超的公司。
小雪他們本來以為。
徐超會像中介銷售一樣。
先是假裝友好
給一些不通不癢的回答。
等問到重要問題的時候。
就開始收取費用
但沒有想到的是
不管小雪跟他的朋友。
問了多少問題
花了徐超多少時間和精力。
徐超始終是保持著一副。
十分耐心的解惑的樣子。
免費回答著他們咨詢的。
一個又一個的問題。
不光是求職取道方式上的建議。
甚至還有未來職業發展。
規劃相關的咨詢
徐超都為他們兩個人。
詳細的分析和介紹了。
那小雪他們在一個。
陌生的國家裏
感受到了來自
國人的慷慨和友善。
對呀 這太容易讓人放低。
防備性了吧？
這不僅僅是客戶和。
獵頭中介的關係
也更代表著一份
在海外的
同鄉與同鄉之間
相互幫助的情誼
因為咨詢完後
他們就互相留了一些。
聯繫方式
所以在聊天的過程當中。
小雪就發現
徐超竟然還跟自己。
是老鄉
而且還有很多
共同話題
雖然年紀差的滿多。
但徐超為人非常善良。
很會照顧人
經常能夠給到一些。
過來人的建議
慢慢的
因為都是在
英國的華人嘛？
小雪跟她的朋友們。
就開始和徐超他們一圈。
經常線下聚會
處的呢 就像朋友一樣。
也就這樣
徐超就提出
在2025年
5月31日
來到她家一起吃頓飯。
聊會天
也是非常多人的
這種聚會嗎
是的
雖然是第一次來到徐超家。
但小雪他們並沒有。
感到不安或者害怕。
首先因為是
之前他們
已經見過很多次了。
他們認為
徐超這個人
是相當不錯的
而且徐超是有女朋友的。
這個
他們年紀差距也大。
就不太會有
幹壞事的可能性嘛？
其次呢？
這次聚會安排的人。
也是非常之多
與其收拾聚會
用徐超的原話來講。
這是一次職業社交活動。
除了小雪的好幾個姐妹。
徐超那邊還有5個朋友。
說不定呢？
對他們未來找工作。
還有一些幫助
於是
5月31日
小雪就跟朋友們
一起來到了徐超的家裡。
徐超的家很大
他們將近10個人。
先是吃了一會兒燒烤。
簡單喝了幾杯酒
氣氛都很不錯
隨後呢？
徐超就端上來了
像是
酒吧里面
可樂桶那樣的
大容量的雞尾酒桶。
你應該能
知道那個什麼樣子吧？
徐超就說
這是用酒精跟中藥。
調製而成的獨家秘製雞尾酒。
取名叫做生命之泉。
並且勸說
小雪跟她姐妹們嘗試一下。
畢竟里面有來自
老家中國的中藥嘛？
結果
小雪喝下這杯酒之後。
不到半個小時
立刻就感到頭很暈。
並且說想要休息一下。
抱怨徐超的酒
調的太濃了
小雪的其他姐妹也喝了。
他們喝過之後就覺得。
嘴會立刻變得非常乾。
感覺是非常非常高濃度的酒。
才會有的那種口感。
徐超在得知
小雪想要休息之後。
就顫抖著她
到了自己的臥室里。
隨後的記憶
小雪的印象里就非常模糊了。
小雪在喝完
這個所謂的生命之泉之後。
只覺得自己的頭
非常暈
很口渴
在徐超床上
休息的這段時間
小雪的朋友
也來過這裡
看過小雪好幾次
甚至還想給小雪餵點水。
就是幫助代謝一下。
小雪當時的眼睛
是怎麼都長不開
頭是怎麼都抬不起來。
在小雪僅存的
斷了續續的記憶當中。
她一會看到徐超
正在脫自己的衣服和裙子。
一會兒正在暴力的。
性侵自己
甚至還在不停的
擺弄自己的身體
小雪用僅存的力氣。
進行反抗
而結果就是
徐超發現了小雪
並不是深度的昏迷狀態。
她怕小雪有記憶
她把小雪清醒之後反映過來。
於是徐超離開房間。
之後又端過來另一杯飲品。
逼迫小雪喝下去
小雪不知道這是什麼。
只記得這杯液體
非常的甜
昏迷中的她猜想
這是用來掩蓋其他味道。
所以才故意調的這麼甜。
於是小雪
強大最後的力氣振作。
試著吐出來
結果呢？
徐超拿來了
第一罐狀的藥劑
繼續開始為著小雪喝下去。
這個是沒有經過
稀釋的藥品嗎
對的
小雪只感到自己
失去了所有力氣
頭越來越沉
半夢半醒之間
小雪覺得
徐超好像有點不耐煩了。
開始用力掐著她的身體。
小雪感覺到痛
睜開眼
卻看到徐超一隻手。
以及對著自己
另一隻手
正在掀開自己的裙子。
就是小雪僅有的最後的記憶。
第二天醒來後
小雪依然感覺
四肢沒什麼力氣
藥力下去之後
小雪開始感受到
自己的私密部位
傳來的疼痛
但這還不是
最讓她擔心的
周正豪案件爆發之後。
身為同在英國的
華人女性
小雪自然也是知道的。
她怕她記憶中
最後的畫面
是真實的
她怕徐超拍下了
自己裸體的照片
這是小雪才意識到。
這會兒已經是第二天的。
下午1點了
在往外走的過程中。
小雪還發現
跟自己一起來的姐妹。
就在徐超家的沙發上躺著。
前有周正豪前車之鑑。
小雪立刻把姐妹叫醒。
並且告訴了她
昨晚到底發生了什麼。
聽到小雪的講究之後。
他們當即就決定
要找到徐超對峙
起碼也一定要看著他。
刪掉小雪的錄像才行。
但當他們倆找到徐超之後。
徐超表現出來那種。
慢不進行的態度
卻更讓他們受不了。
他們問
昨晚到底對小雪做了什麼。
徐超說
不知道啊？
喝大了都
他們問
到底有沒有碰小雪。
徐超說
喝大了
可能碰了
也可能沒碰吧？
所以他要把這個事情。
包裝成所謂的酒後亂性。
他們問
是不是拍了小雪的視頻。
徐超說
可能拍了
也可能沒拍吧？
喝大了不知道
裝傻唄
對
就針對徐超這個說辭。
如果說碰沒碰
第二天可能一時間。
拿不出證據
但如果說你拍了
那你打開視頻
就能看到呀？
對吧？
小雪跟姐妹
就立刻要求
檢查徐超的手機
但徐超就是不給看。
小雪跟姐妹
此時就意識到
徐超絕對是拍了視頻的。
於是立刻
打電話給徐超的女朋友。
逼迫徐超刪除
手機上小雪的照片和視頻。
但就算這樣
徐超還是拒絕了
最後
甚至他們說
不刪視頻就報警的時候。
徐超還能嘴硬
說就是不給看
已經給機會
給到這種程度了
好吧？
小雪跟她的姐妹
才一起報了警
再等警察
過來了這段時間
昨晚的藥性
還是沒有退乾淨
小雪還是有
嚴重的頭暈
以及口渴的反應
於是呢？
就開始休息
小雪的朋友
去給小雪倒水
此時
只剩下
神智清醒的徐超藝人。
她不會趁著警方
還沒到的時候
把視頻給偷偷刪掉了吧？
小雪在昏迷後醒來之後。
第一時間也意識到這個問題了。
下午3點前
警方才抵達了現場。
剛到徐超家裏
聽完小雪的敘述後。
當場就扣押了徐超。
以及徐超的手機
同時也包含徐超家裏。
昨晚做的雞尾酒
這個徐超下的藥
藥性強到什麼程度呢？
等到小雪在警局
等體檢的時候
都再次昏迷睡著了。
檢測顯示
小雪呈現出異常的。
低血壓
以及脫水狀態
在小雪的尿檢樣本中。
醫生還發現
有常用作迷藥的
化學毒品相關痕跡。
以及肌肉鬆弛劑
這兩種藥物
也導致小雪的昏迷。
失憶
和無法求救
和反抗的相關症狀。
還有更可怕
你知道是什麼嗎
什麼
前面我們說
徐超很有可能
會在警方來之前
把照片視頻刪掉嗎。
對啊？
我也很擔心
因為這是很直接的。
犯罪證據
但他沒有
他為什麼不刪呢？
他就狂妄到這種程度。
在警方扣押的
徐超手機裡
警方找到了
93張照片
以及30條以上的視頻。
這並不是徐超有史以來。
所有的犯罪證據
這些內容的拍攝時間。
無一例外
全部都是在
6月1日凌晨1點55分。
到早上6點半的這個時間內。
拍攝下來的
詳細的拍攝內容
我就不過頭展開了。
相信大家都知道
這裡面是什麼
報案後的第四天
警方已經確認了
徐超對小雪實施性侵的。
基本事實
開始針對了對徐超家裡。
進行更徹底的搜查。
在這輪搜查當中
警方發現
徐超不僅僅是一個。
利用陷阱對女性實施性侵。
並拍下犯罪內容的強姦犯。
他更是一個在生活裡。
無處不在對女性
進行性剝削的施暴者。
除了與實施性侵相關的。
違法迷藥毒品
根據不完全統計
警方在徐超家裡還發現了。
偽裝成空氣清新劑的隱藏攝像頭。
偽裝成中表的隱藏攝像頭。
偽裝成音響的隱藏攝像頭。
甚至是塞在衛生經理的隱藏攝像頭。
除此之外
還有各種各樣
花樣擺出的隱藏攝像頭。
以及包括但不限於眾多在徐超家裡。
洗手間
臥室
公司
地鐵
等公共交通上偷拍的女性洗澡。
換衣服
以及公共場所下女性的群體視頻。
時間跨度上涵蓋了從。
2022年2月到2025年6月。
長達3年04個月拍攝的所有內容。
其中涉及到的偷拍。
以及性侵的受害者。
數量已經達到了上百人。
朋友
室友
同事
以及陌生人
都是徐超的縱然對象。
徐超甚至還會把多個不同的性侵視頻。
剪輯在一起
做成合集混剪的樣子。
我們不知道這些視頻最終都流向到了什麼地方。
也不知道徐超都用這些視頻做過什麼。
此外
警方還在這些視頻圖像內容中發現。
小雪並不是唯一一名受害者。
根據涉及到性侵的內容推斷。
徐超連環性侵案中的受害者至少有13名。
其中還包含當天與小雪一起報案的。
小雪的朋友小葉
警方在徐超的手機裡。
找到了徐超性侵小葉時拍攝的。
40條以上的視頻以及76張照片。
而拍攝時間顯示
是在2024年10月13日。
之前的事情
對
那小葉這次怎麼還跟小雪一起來。
說明她對當天發生的事情。
什麼都不知道
其實小葉那天睡醒。
小雪告知她發生什麼的時候。
她心裡就隱約開始有了這種預感。
因為小雪說的
跟她2024年10月在徐超家裡發生的情況。
簡直一模一樣
但她當時還以為是自己喝太多的問題。
現在才知道
原來她早就遭受到了徐超的心情。
本來是想幫助小雪報警的小葉。
現在也成為了徐超連環性侵案中的。
受害者之一
當她做好心理準備。
看完徐超所拍下的視頻以後。
她的情緒就開始陷入到了某種。
極度的恐懼當中
她開始害怕睡覺
她害怕睡著後的自己遭受到。
來自不知道哪裡的傷害。
她害怕自己的視頻。
不知道什麼時候會在哪裡出現。
也更怕徐超出獄後對他們進行報復。
而小雪開始遠離男性。
她害怕接觸到任何一個。
可能會讓她連想到徐超。
以及性侵的男性
此時的她
雖然已經如願以償的。
找到了在英國的工作。
但這件事情對她造成的心理創傷。
已經讓她無法正常地繼續工作下去。
法定上小雪和小葉。
以及其他受害者一起。
提供受害者陳述
小雪說
徐超偷走了自己原本的樣子。
她為自己給徐超
介紹過自己的其他女性朋友。
而感到深深的內疚和自走。
她再也不敢參加這種社交活動。
她不敢告訴家人
她也不敢再輕易相信海外的同胞。
徐超改變了她的人生。
考慮到犯罪行為極度惡劣。
以及對其他女性構成的。
相當程度的危險性。
最終徐超被法院判處。
無期徒刑
在假釋委員會
第一次進行暗戒審理前。
必須服完的最低刑期委。
13年零200天。
這個時間會根據監獄裏面。
表現而進行變化
如果假釋成功
徐超的一生都需要。
向警方通報個人信息。
當然因為是中國公民。
在復興滿後
就可能被自動驅逐回中國。
兩個案子聽完之後。
我們忍不住會驚訝心來想想。
究竟是什麼樣的環境。
能夠幫助他們
實施一次又一次
如此懦弱又卑鄙的性侵呢？
那些藥物都是非法藥品。
誰交給他們那麼多。
如何下藥以及偷拍的技巧呢？
他拍攝那麼多的視頻。
究竟是為了什麼
難道只是為了自己看嗎。
警方當時在利用代碼。
分析了周正豪的電腦之後發現。
他在2020年11月。
曾經下載過一本教程手冊。
這並不是一本教你。
如何整理花園或者是。
使用工具的教程手冊。
而是教授你如何下藥。
並且迷姦女性的手冊。
在手冊的內容中
包含了事無巨細的。
下藥手法
用量等相關內容介紹。
還在周正豪的手機裏。
發現了眾多迷藥的廣告。
廣告的畫面裏
無一例外
全部都是
看起來熟睡狀態下的女性。
旁邊寫著幾個字
保證效果
就是如此變態和扭曲的廣告。
堂而皇之的出現在這裏。
原來迷姦
早就變成了這些圈子裏。
習以為常的話題
甚至是一門生意
而且在這兩個案件中。
還有相同的地方是。
他們在社交軟件上。
都有上百萬條
加起來可能有上千萬條。
關於營會色情裏的。
聊天的信息
我們不由得會去想。
這些群組的背後
都是誰呢？
難道他們也都是
清清範疇嗎
他們也都是如此高學歷。
高收入的人員嗎
還是
僅僅看起來
都是普通人呢？
那接下來
我們就進入到一個這樣的群組。
看看裏面
都是一些什麽樣的人。
張大鵬
出生於
中國東北吉林的一個小建成裏。
家裏條件
不算很富裕
但在當地也屬於中上。
2002年
從哈爾濱工業大學。
同步工程畢業之後。
就聽從了
從事工程裏行業的。
親戚建議
開始去到了德國留學。
學完語言班之後
2005年到2014年。
張大鵬在德國
徒兵跟大學
沒有繼續學習建築。
而是轉去學習
計算機轉業
類似於本碩聯讀
因為那個年代
留學的人不多
所以張大鵬的爸爸媽媽。
只要一在
零里間
聊起自己的兒子
總是帶著
滿滿的驕傲跟自豪。
一聊
就能聊好幾個小時。
而獨自在
德國留學期
呢張大鵬呢？
雖然說性格上比較孤僻。
和人正常打交道
比較困難
但是互聯網上的他。
性格卻非常的體貼。
和主動
當時的女朋友小穎。
也就是因為這一點。
才跟張大鵬在一起的。
張大鵬在這段關係裏。
有一個外號
就是二哈
哈士奇
只要小穎一說他生氣了。
張大鵬立刻就會表示。
自己正在
說小多聽
以此來哄小穎開心。
除了這些
張大鵬也會在當時的。
德國華人論壇裏
頻繁的發帖互動
他感興趣的領域
主要集中在技術板塊。
攝影板塊
以及汽車板塊
此外還額外管理著一個。
攝影愛好群
光是統計他的在線時長。
就有
2390個小時
可是
人不能總活在網上。
對吧？
張大鵬因為性格上比較切弱。
在2014年
碩士畢業之後
整整一年時間都沒有找到工作。
他其實
學歷什麼都不錯
但是呢就是跟別人說話的時候。
不敢看對方的眼睛。
交流上也不能流利的表達自己。
給人一種味味瘦瘦的感覺。
很不自信
所以面試就一直過不了。
以至於最後
還是小穎
通過自己的人際關係。
把張大鵬
介紹到了一家
以華人為主的
在德國的公司的
這也是張大鵬在德國的。
第一份工作
張大鵬的家人對他很好。
工作剛一年時間
還沒有存下什麼錢。
他爸媽就出錢
幫他在德國買了一套。
110平米的房子。
首付10萬歐元
還有20多萬歐元的貸款。
張大鵬常說
自己的家裡
有一個明確的計劃。
那就是
40歲之前必須結婚。
但離譜的是
跟小穎在一起之前。
其實他就是已婚的。
什麼意思
就是他在讀書之前。
已經結了婚了
然後他出軌
跟小穎在一起了
然後現在他又以此為理由。
催小穎跟他結婚
這也讓小穎感覺
張大鵬這個人不太負責。
所謂的結婚
只是為了完成任務。
那2022年
41歲的張大鵬
可以說是人生
一個重要的轉折點。
此時的他
去年剛剛結了婚
這會兒呢？
又剛好跳槽
到另一家公司裡
已經來德國生活20年了。
或許
自己之後的生活
也能繼續一番豐順呢？
他想
這家新的公司
也是華人開設的
在德國的分公司
只不過地理位置變了。
在德國的紐倫堡
這個地方
張大鵬很早之前就來過。
因為他的愛好是攝影。
所以喜歡到各種地方。
拍一些美麗的風景。
現在因為工作原因。
再次來到這裡
他其實還挺開心的。
因為就在他
尋找新房子住宿的時候。
他就想到了一個人。
小花
就是張大鵬在德國。
認識的唯數不多的。
幾個外國人之一
因為性格孤僻
所以張大鵬在這裡的朋友。
大部分都還是中國人。
之所以認識並記得小花。
其實是因為他之前。
來紐倫堡的時候
在Irbnb上
訂購他的房子
所以張大鵬就想
要不
這次來紐倫堡工作。
短租也住他家
於是張大鵬
就計劃起了這次的拜訪。
他記得小花
在之前短暫的借助期間。
以及聊天當中
小花跟張大鵬
簡單聊過幾句
關於自己的生活
他是一位單親媽媽。
早些時候離了婚
女兒現在還不到一歲。
需要一直照顧
但是小花經濟條件。
其實並不是很好
他沒有辦法長時間的工作。
因為要時刻照顧女兒。
這個年齡段的小孩。
還離不開自己
但如果不努力的工作賺錢。
自己跟女兒的物質。
又很難得到保障
小花最害怕的就是。
自己被社會機構
判定為缺乏養育能力。
然後讓他們
把自己的孩子帶走。
所以小花
才會靠不斷的出租。
自己家裡的
其中一個房間
到Irbnb上
來賺取一點額外的收入。
張大鵬想到這裡
就打開了一個臨時帶。
拿出了裡面
其中一粒藥物
然後
把它放進了一枚巧克力裡。
被張大鵬拿出來的。
這裡的藥物
它們俗稱為
三
因為它的名字叫做。
三座輪
是一種謎罪祭
藥小藥比普通的安定藥。
要強個
四十五到一百倍
所以在他們這種群僚裡。
就常被用
直接的三來指代
而這裡張大鵬
所用的藥物
則是他在幾個月前。
寄出去給買家
結果被退回來的三。
他竟然還售賣這種藥物嗎。
對的
這個被退回來的三座輪。
這段時間就一直在臨時代裡。
被油漬經了很久
他不知道
這到底有沒有影響到藥效。
於是
抱著不浪費
試一試的心態
他決定
把它重新用起來
2022年7月18日這天。
小花打開門後很開心。
因為之前張大鵬
早就戒速過
小娃還記得她
所以對待張大鵬
更像是對待一個朋友一樣。
張大鵬也說
好久不見
這次來到小花家裡借助。
就準備了一些伴手禮。
比方說這個巧克力。
如果不介意的話
可以嘗一嘗
小花接過
這枚裝了米藥的巧克力。
後就吃了下去
沒過一段時間
就在臥室的床上
陷入了昏迷
張大鵬此時心裡
感到有些驚喜
於是
又馬上熟練的給小花。
戴上了布滿另一種藥物。
欺負迷的透明呼吸面罩。
讓小花持續的保持昏迷狀態。
最後又給小花注射了。
一支第三種藥物
米達作倫
至此
米藥三件套
才算全部用完
在張大鵬群鳥裡
這三件套
是每次犯罪必備的。
三種藥物
在交流中
都會用暗語代替
除了前面說的
三就是三作倫以外。
還有七
指的就是放在呼吸面罩裡的。
欺負迷
以及粒
就是給小花注射的米達作倫。
這種使得受害者
進入到深度昏迷的給藥方式。
也正是張大鵬所在的群鳥裡。
相互指導教學
和分享使用經驗的。
最主要的犯罪手段。
在這三種藥物用完以後。
小花此刻已經進入到了。
深度的昏迷狀態
根據專業的麻醉醫師分析。
這三種正經類藥物。
會直接作用於中樞神經。
以及其他維持生命的。
重要生理過程
三種藥物中的任意一種。
在單獨拿出來使用的時候。
都需要經過
嚴格的把控用藥方式。
最基礎的則是需要讓。
患者在用藥之前
保持近時空腹狀態。
各種醫生在旁邊
時刻觀察患者的情況。
比方說呼吸的暗化碳。
心跳以及血壓等等。
同時還有麻醉後的舌頭後縮。
胃部的食物反流
或者嘔吐物進入肺部。
導致患者的呼吸道阻塞。
以及功能性肺衰解。
甚至直接窒息死亡。
他這種藥就這樣隨便用。
不怕受害者會直接。
有生命危險嗎
是啊？
此時的小花
正是處於這種
三種藥物疊加使用的狀態。
所受到的傷害和死亡風險。
都是成倍增加的
張大鵬知道小花
要面臨的風險
但在他的眼裡
此時的小花
並不是一個人
不是房東
也不是他為數不多的。
德國朋友
而是一台車
甚至還不如一台車。
一台車的豪華與否。
起碼正常人類還會關心。
而此時張大鵬
只在乎自己在性侵時。
方不方便
被下了重度迷藥的小花。
面對張大鵬暴力的性侵。
產生了身體本能的抗拒。
但他沒有力氣
也沒有意識
只能勉強地使用
四肢試圖進行抵抗。
這讓張大鵬感到厭煩。
他隨機變馬小花的四肢。
牢牢捆綁在一起
進行固定
之後張大鵬開始駕舍。
自己用於拍攝
此次性侵視頻的攝像機。
在性侵的過程當中。
小花11個月大的女兒。
醒來過兩次
但張大鵬並沒有感到害怕。
用奶瓶餵完孩子睡著後。
繼續對小花的信心。
時間長到小孩第三次醒來。
這次因為小孩
哭喊的聲音實在是太大了。
張大鵬怕小花被吵醒。
才不得已結束
張大鵬不僅不慢地。
收拾好做完工具以後。
感到疲倦的他
並沒有從小花的家裏逃走。
而是到了小花家裏。
另一個房間裏睡了一晚。
好好休息
因為他知道小花不會醒來。
第二天他才從小花家裏離開。
離開後的張大鵬
像一個32人名為克服群的群裏。
興奮地分享著自己的做案經過。
他說
之前寄出去的3
過了幾個月被退回來了。
所以我自己用了
他一直裝在臨時袋裏。
被油浸了很久
但好像沒有影響藥效。
我就把他放進了巧克力裏。
讓一輛車給吃了
然後順利開了一輛。
大羊馬
如此信任張大鵬的小花。
此刻變成了他口中的大羊馬。
並且作為戰力品
被張大鵬在群裏分享著。
做案經過和信心的細節。
而張大鵬所用的名藥藥性之大。
直到第二天小花睡醒。
都沒有意識到張大鵬到底做了什麽。
他同時也陷入到了一種疑惑。
疑惑的並不是
察覺到自己身體上所受到的傷害。
而是一向友善的張大鵬。
為什麽突然不告而別。
直接離開了自己的家。
而這個疑惑一直到2024年後。
張大鵬被捕
警方憑藉張大鵬硬盤裏的。
性侵視頻
聯繫到小花的時候。
才被解開
原來自己也是張大鵬。
連環性侵案中的受害者之一。
太可怕了
在2022年7月18日。
性侵完小花之後的不到兩個月內。
8月30日
張大鵬試圖再向一位。
新公司的同事實施性侵。
也要注意
他這會剛跳走到這個新公司。
他偽裝成想要幫他搬家的樣子。
到了他家之後
就給這位女同事的成之裏下了迷藥。
等到女同事昏迷後。
張大鵬不知道為什麽。
沒有繼續實施性侵。
而是對著熟睡的他。
拍了幾張照片就離開了。
但就在這次犯案當中。
張大鵬迎來了
第一次警方的調查。
這次他為什麽被警方調查。
是因為這位女同事家裏。
其實裝了監控
女同事在中國的丈夫。
在攝像頭裏看到了張大鵬。
不停地對著自己的妻子拍照。
當即就報了警
但是因為上頭並沒有拍到。
張大鵬實施性犯罪的過程。
所以警方並沒有立案。
也沒有對這位受害者。
進行要件
張大鵬狡辯說
只是覺得女同事睡著的樣子。
很可愛所以才拍了照片。
這件事情最後
雖然沒有讓張大鵬被逮捕。
但是通過在公司內部舉報。
張大鵬就被剛
跳槽的這家新公司開除了。
這才有的後來
張大鵬入職跑車
路特斯品牌當IT經理的工作。
不知道是不是這次。
警方調查行為震懾住了他。
在2023年整年。
德國警方沒有發現。
張大鵬的任何作案經過。
但根據張大鵬本人所說。
從2023年12月。
張大鵬和妻子
在中國度假的時候。
他又在小武術等平台上。
發現了一個新的作案方向。
那就是華人留學生租房圈。
是那種租房群嗎
我也通過類似的這種方式租房子過。
因為就是很多華人。
在海外互幫互助
對呀什麼豆瓣群啊衛健群啊？
很多
張大鵬在德國生活了20年。
並且一開始也是
留學生的身份來到德國的。
所以他太知道留學生的生活。
是一個什麼狀態了。
留學生每次到放假的時候。
就想著說
不要讓房子空著
能多收回本一點是一點嗎。
對呀短租超多
所以就會在小武術的平台發佈一些。
短租的公告
而德國的租房市場。
因為房源少
外國人租房困難
房東審核也比較嚴格。
所以華人與華人之間的。
轉租或者是短租就比較常見。
一方面是交流方便。
另一方面也是因為。
來自同一個國家
有一種天然的信任。
於是不再滿足於熟人圈。
同事朋友的張大鵬。
就開始的對中國女留學生的。
瘋狂狩獵
他會以替女朋友看房。
或者是先替女朋友把東西。
搬到這裡為藉口
上門對女留學生實施性侵。
德國警方發現
到這個階段張大鵬的犯案手段。
明顯有了升級
在之前張大鵬會先偷偷。
把三座輪放到飲品。
或者食物中迷倒受害者。
之後再給他們戴上。
忽入式的麻藥
之後注入迷答坐輪。
但現在張大鵬
則是直接會把不滿。
欺負迷的不
捂住受害者的口鼻。
令受害者瞬間陷入昏迷。
可以看出來
張大鵬的整個犯罪行動都開始。
變得更加大膽和暴力。
從2024年1月6日。
開始到1月9日
短短四天
張大鵬連續作案三起。
也是在這段期間
開始有了第一位受害者報案。
到8月
張大鵬的妻子流產出院。
在家休養的這段期間。
張大鵬繼續開始作案。
還是同樣的說法
先是在小巫書上以女性的名義。
預約看房
最後在看房期間對房東實施信心。
在2024年8月23日。
張大鵬信心了一位。
年近18歲的學生。
並且拍攝了長達兩個小時。
39分鐘的視頻
受害者在此次被刑警之後。
出現了多次嘔吐的症狀。
在一週內的
8月30日
張大鵬在群聊裡說。
今天本來想開一輛。
但是我的妻不夠了。
得留著開另外一個小網紅。
張大鵬所說的這名小網紅。
就是已知的張大鵬。
連環性侵案中
最後一位受害者
小子
在2024年9月1日下午。
張大鵬和小子約定了看房時間。
張大鵬趁氣不備
用7米幅5柱了
小子的口碧
把他迷暈之後
開始用手機在群內。
直播自己的性情過程。
張大鵬說
他是個中國妹子
看著是挺好看的
但他一開口氣氛就沒了。
而且他劈圖劈得太狠。
完全不像照片上的樣子。
性情結束後直到第二天的。
中心搶從昏迷中醒過來。
這次的昏迷市場
長達12個小時
和以往不同的是
張大鵬這次並沒有選擇隱藏。
自己的犯罪證據和痕跡。
偷偷的一聲不坑溜走。
還處在神智不是很清醒的小子。
在淋亂的房間內
發現了一例
緊急避孕藥
以及一張張大鵬用。
中文寫的紙條
內容是
這是避孕藥
如果你擔心
可以服用這粒緊急避孕藥。
我是受了他人之託。
拍了照片和視頻
如果你乖乖配合不伸張。
你可以當做什麼都沒有發生過。
就當做了一場夢否則。
你的熟人和整個互聯網。
都可以欣賞這些美照。
看到這裡
小子當機就報了警。
他沒有陷入張大鵬的威脅。
而這最後一次報案。
也順利的
將張大鵬送到了監獄裏。
2024年9月23日。
德國警方
用中、英、德、三裕。
發佈了一則警情農保。
提醒在德國的華人女性。
緊急避孕可能是中國級的。
連環強姦犯
精明強姦犯的慣用手法。
就是通過偽裝成女性。
在網絡上特別是小紅書和微信。
以租房或者是過夜為目的。
預約上門看房
最後實施性侵
其實從1月份第一期報案以來。
德國警方就一直試圖找到。
張大鵬的蹤跡
但因為張大鵬使用的是中國的石膠軟件。
德國的警方
很難通過平台方
直接獲取張大鵬的個人信息。
所以一直進展緩慢。
在小子報案之後
警方判斷案情的危害性。
直線升級
在2024年10月。
由德國黑森州刑事調查局。
他們隨即就通過國際行政組織。
向位於中國警方
發出正式的協助請求。
中國方面在2024年。
11月14日凌晨。
就向德國警方傳回了張大鵬。
在微信以及小紅書。
兩個平台上綁定的手機號碼。
而當德國警方
調查號碼的主人信息時候就發現。
持有者正是張大鵬本人。
隨後
德國警方通過手機信號塔。
數據發現
在小子提供的縱按時間範圍內。
張大鵬的手機號碼。
正巧出現在了這附近。
自此警方鎖定了
張大鵬的犯罪嫌疑人身份。
並且在當天中午
在張大鵬的公司附近。
將他證實逮捕
逮捕張大鵬後
德國警方在張大鵬的住處裏。
找到了大量的本二彈著類藥物。
其實就是直接作用於。
中樞神經系統的證據類藥物。
提到的張大鵬所使用的各種。
名藥
還搜查到了
63個數據儲存設備。
這個數字什麼概念呢？
我們不可做到現在。
近一百期節目
我保存了所有的
圓門鍵以及工程門鍵。
連一個硬盤都沒有裝滿。
而張大鵬有足足
63個類似的設備。
並且警方在其中幾個硬盤裏。
還找到了
一份涉及未成年兒童的。
色情文件
那現在人眾物證確鑿。
張大鵬也抓到了
接下來就是警方的調查。
因為他們知道如此。
閒熟的作案手法
以及保留下來大量的。
性侵錄製影像
受害者絕對不止
四位報案人這麼簡單。
但迷煎跟強姦還不一樣。
使用大量危險的
對人體造成的傷害。
免刑的就是順行性遺忘。
也就是大多數受害者。
表現出來的那樣
第二天醒來後
根本都不知道在自己身上。
發生了什麽
用張大鵬在群鳥裏。
分享的經驗所說
最完美的情況就是。
受害者在迷醉中醒來。
這樣他還有意識
還能反抗
這個時候情況就從迷煎。
變成了強姦
的話
一次就能獲得多種體驗。
受害者對於這部分記憶的缺失。
也導致了他們在案發後。
根本就無法意識到。
自己遭受過性侵
也就無法報案
警方只能通過扣押的。
張大鵬的硬盤
電腦以及手機
一個個排查受害者的真實身份。
這才找到了
張大鵬連環性侵案中的更多。
受害者
和性侵的RNBNB。
房東小花
小花在警局裏看完視頻後。
立刻就陷入到了
深深的愧疚和自責當中。
兩年多時間過去了。
他不知道在這段時間裏。
這個視頻到底被發到了哪裏。
他不知道自己的同事。
有沒有看到過
他也不知道應該如何重新。
面對自己的工作
同時他也在不斷的責怪自己。
沒有保護好女兒
他也不知道當天張大鵬。
有沒有給他的女兒下過藥。
他也不確定張大鵬。
有沒有對自己的女兒。
進行任何的猥褻或者是心情。
小花後知後覺的痛苦。
直到2026年
對張大鵬的判決結束後。
也沒有停止
這一年多的時間
小花無法正常的生活。
他怕張大鵬拍攝的情景視頻。
被熟人看過
他不敢睡覺
給家裏人和朋友
但小花最怕的還是。
自己因為這件事情。
被社會福利機構
認定為不合格的母親。
把女兒
從他的生活裏帶走。
2025年10月。
隨著對張大鵬的案件取得了一定進展。
跟多位受害人建立聯繫後。
張大鵬連環性侵案。
在法蘭克福地區法院。
正式開庭審理
在審理環節
多位受害女性出庭作證。
其中甚至還有一位是。
瞞著家人飛到德國。
參加的庭審
在這之前他其實有過猶豫。
因為張大鵬性侵
已經過去四年半的時間了。
如今的他
已經在國內順利組建了家庭。
他不希望家人知道這件事情。
雖然是張大鵬的錯。
是張大鵬對他造成的。
心理和身體上的傷害。
犯錯的人並不是他。
但他
還是會感受到
十分的羞愧
邀請他來出庭作證的警方告訴他。
德國法庭
針對類似案件的審理。
雖然證人可以通過文字形式。
本人不到場
來為庭審提供幫助。
但也是會通過
觀察庭審現場這人的狀態。
來考慮對犯人
進行從重量刑的
而他
聽到了這裡
才下定決心前往德國。
參加對張大鵬的庭審。
當他來到現場之後。
他在旁聽席上
看到其他和自己處境。
相同的女性
以及一直低了頭
始終不敢直視他們的張大鵬。
他覺得
他來對了
在這裡這些女性的目的只有一個。
那就是讓張大鵬得到應有的懲罰。
2026年2月7日。
張大鵬連環性侵害的一支受害者。
至少有
10名女性
在檢方提起的22項罪名中。
其中包括非法
經營麻醉藥品
傳播暴力色情內容。
危險傷害他人
以及特別嚴重性質的強姦。
還有殺人未遂
最終判處張大鵬
14年有期徒刑
以及行滿後的
預防性激壓
也需要賠償每位受害者。
5位屬歐元的賠償。
共計23.3萬歐元。
他為什麼裁判14年。
就跟英國的比起來感覺很少。
對跟前面提到
周正豪以及徐超暗中的無期徒刑相比。
張大鵬的判刑
顯然是
非常之輕的
才十幾年
那這裡就不得不跟大家簡單介紹下。
德國法律的不同
因為我們後續要講述的兇手一樣。
如果全判的
也會面臨同樣的問題。
就是刑法太低
因為在德國法律上。
量刑採用的是靜合原則。
雖然張大鵬犯下的案件當中。
涉及到殺人未遂
以及特別嚴重性質的強姦。
每一項單拉出來都是。
11年或者12年刑期。
但在德國量刑原則上。
是不會疊加的
而是合併
就是說取一個最高刑期。
再進行適當的加重。
在張大鵬犯下的所有罪行當中。
最嚴重的單向刑期是12年。
法院又根據這個情況。
加重到了14年
所以在他們的法律體育當中。
其實是從重判罰的。
這一點和美國那種。
就是每一項單獨列出來。
最後哪家刑期的計算方式不一樣。
但你要注意啊？
這裡張大鵬14年刑期之後。
是一個預防性羈押。
這個預防性羈押是怎麼回事呢？
就是說被告人出獄之後。
如果說法院
法官認定你這個人對社會。
還有危害性
那就會繼續對他進行關押。
理論上只要判定你還存在風險。
關押就是可以無限期延長的。
但是我覺得這個非常說不准。
因為你不知道這個判斷。
你們危險的標準是什麼。
就是說比較靈活比較主觀。
而且也能做假呀？
所以我覺得這個對我來說。
沒有那麼強的實質性的作用。
首先從罪犯的角度而言。
就是嚴重性就沒有。
其他國家那麼高
那接下來在針對張大鵬。
手機聊天信息的調查當中。
德國警方還發現了一個驚人的現象。
就是如此性質惡劣的張大鵬案。
其實並不是單獨的唯一案件。
在張大鵬的Telegram裏。
警方發現了足足25個。
與迷間相關的群了。
其中人數最多的
有2316名成員。
而這些群組成員
都以中國男性為主。
他們之間交流基本都是中文。
而內容大部分都是交換彼此。
強姦或者是迷間女性的視頻。
相互傳授
分享縱然經驗
以及購買麻醉藥物。
而在經過翻譯和警方了解之後得知。
在他們的黑話體系當中。
有完整的一整套物化女性。
以及實施犯罪的稱呼。
除了前面提到的迷藥相關的3。
指的是3座輪
7指的是7副迷
力指的是迷大座輪之外。
還有被下藥後迷倒的女性。
他們稱為死豬
日常交流裏出現的車。
只帶著女性
私家車指的是熟人。
或者是自己的女朋友或者是妻子。
豪車指的是漂亮的女性。
而油就是迷藥的代稱。
下藥就是加油
性侵就是開車
實施性侵的男性是司機。
性侵經驗豐富的人。
則被稱為是老司機。
而警方也找到了一個名為。
德國老司機駕效的群僚。
在這期中
警方就鎖定了
下一位連環強姦案的。
兇手
蔣忠義
根據張大鵬的私人聊天記錄。
群僚內容警方發現。
有一位男士
曾經多次向張大鵬購買。
迷間所需的藥物
並且他也在多達
四個不同的群組中。
發出了內容一模一樣的話。
他說
一位具備完善資質的歐洲司機。
正在尋找車輛
這句話簡單翻譯一下裏面。
自己
就是他說的地理位置在歐洲。
有性經驗的
格的性侵者
而車輛就是說受害者女性。
如果你是一位陌生人。
你看到這句話一定會認為。
蔣忠義
是一位具備犯罪能力和條件。
但是目前缺少犯罪目標。
所以不得已
才在群組中尋找的新犯罪者。
對吧？
但其實在蔣忠義心裏。
一直都有一個固定的作案對象。
那就是小蘭
什麼叫固定的作案對象。
多次的這個人下手嗎。
是的
但是她一直不記得。
對小蘭自從來到穆尼黑。
念書生活之後就住在了這棟公寓裏。
起初她剛到這裏的時候。
人生地不熟
但好在有另一位住在同一棟樓的。
中國老鄉
時不時的熱情幫助。
小蘭才很快適應了這裏的生活。
並且跟這位中國老鄉。
還建立了不錯的聯繫。
這位中國老鄉
28歲
正在穆尼黑公寓大學。
念機器人學碩士
她的長相較為憨厚。
人也熱情友好
在小蘭搬進這棟樓裏之後。
蔣忠義就多次對小蘭。
進行續航溫暖
展示著自己的善良。
久而久之
因為都是老鄉
蔣忠義又比較照顧小蘭。
住的又這麼近
他們就發展出了幾次自願性的。
上期節目中
錯誤的把蔣忠義和小蘭。
描述為了戀人關係。
其實不是的
他並沒有確立任何正式的。
戀愛關係
僅僅是有發生過性行為的朋友。
或者是伴侶
不知道怎麽的
小蘭發現自己自從跟蔣忠義。
接觸多了以後
就開始出現了斷片。
以及失憶的情況
有的說
而且睡醒之後
頭暈腦脹
渾身很疲憊
不舒服
且伴隨身體很多部位的疼痛。
小蘭開始覺得
是不是自己學業壓力太大。
而導致自己出現精神恍惚。
甚至是焦慮失憶的問題。
小蘭對此感到十分痛苦。
甚至於他跟朋友講的時候。
都說自己
可能有一天會自殺。
但是小蘭自始之中。
都沒有懷疑過蔣忠義。
在蔣忠義的眼裏
小蘭有兩個不同的版本。
一個是他在清醒時。
能夠正常交流
並自願發生性行為的小蘭。
另一個
是小蘭在陷入
冰靈死亡邊緣的重度昏迷時。
被蔣忠義
強行實施性侵的小蘭。
高中時期的蔣忠義。
給自己取外號叫重炮。
來讓他人感覺到
自己的性能力方面的強大。
在與朋友聊起
未來的人生理想時。
他認真的說
希望未來的自己
能夠被女生口交
因為這樣會有征服的感覺。
當下朋友立刻就意識到。
蔣忠義志在於此
因為看得出來
蔣忠義並不是在跟他開玩笑。
同時心地力
也深感震驚
但蔣忠義對女性的厭惡和渴望。
並不是從高中才開始的。
從小時候的蔣忠義就覺得。
睡著的女性很美
他喜歡能夠認自己。
隨意擺佈的女性的狀態。
他可憐的權力支配感。
也只能以如此
卑微懦弱的方式獲取。
也因此
他可悲的心靈很容易破碎。
換句話說
很容易破防
在蔣忠義讓小蘭陷入昏迷。
實施性侵的過程中。
因為要效隨著時間。
逐漸減弱
小蘭
開始逐漸有了意識。
擁有了反抗的能力。
小蘭感受到痛苦
她開始收緊雙腿
小蘭意識到有人正在對她進行性侵。
於是
她的雙手開始用力推開。
這是一個人在面對。
危險時候的本能反應。
但微弱的反抗
卻讓蔣忠義覺得
自己正在失去某些權力。
這是她脆弱的自尊心。
所不可接受的
於是
蔣忠義開始拼命的。
加大麻醉藥物伎倆。
此時的她
已經不在乎小蘭的死活。
她只想重新奪回
本就不屬於她的權力。
她想要的是一個
能夠任人擺佈的
陷入重度昏迷的小蘭。
根據後續庭審中
出現的職業麻醉師證明。
蔣忠義在小蘭身上。
單次使用的迷藥劑量。
是醫院處方用量的。
5到10倍
在警方根據
張大鵬的聊天記錄。
以及藥物購買往來記錄中。
德國警方順利追蹤到了。
蔣忠義所處的位置。
並且對她進行了突襲。
而令警方恐懼的是。
此時被逮捕的
蔣忠義的身邊
就是昏迷了
好幾個小時的小蘭。
而直到這一天
小蘭才知道了
自己一直以來
昏迷失憶的真相
警方隨後
在蔣忠義的公寓抽屜裏。
搜出了各種麻醉藥劑。
注射器
口塞等做完工具
又在她的iPad裏。
發現了超過850份。
色情和性侵照片視頻。
其中不少都被她發送給了。
和張大鵬的聊天記錄。
以及各種性侵群聊當中。
蔣忠義從2020年開始。
就混濟於各種
民間群聊裏
其中人數最多的
是名稱為
和平飯店的群組
成員有4600名以上。
遍佈歐洲不同國家。
在逮捕蔣忠義之後。
警方起訴
蔣忠義至少7次
對小藍進行下藥迷煎等行為。
有些藥劑
甚至還直接下入了。
牛奶或者酸奶裏
這也大大增加了
在麻醉期間受害者窒息的風險。
而在蔣忠義錄製的視頻中。
重度昏迷狀態下
受害者發出的憨生。
正是因為舌頭下墜。
而導致的冰淩窒息時。
所發生的聲音
這非但沒有讓蔣忠義停止做完。
甚至還讓他有了
病態的快感
蔣忠義明知這有可能。
會導致受害者的死亡。
卻依然繼續實施犯罪。
最終
2026年4月11日。
穆尼黑第一地方法院。
判處蔣忠義11年。
零三個月的有期徒刑。
外加保留預防信息。
其中有六項特別
嚴重性質的強姦
以及兩項殺人未遂。
判決中法官指出
在蔣忠義所有變態在犯罪裏。
受害者沒有死
全部都是因為運氣好。
僥倖才活了下來
但蔣忠義卻說
他認為死亡才是例外。
他在民間群裏
曾經看到過一次例外。
那就是
有群友說
他在深圳下藥時
有一位女性因此死亡了。
而那位蔣忠義所說的。
在深圳
因為用藥過量
而死亡的女性
至今還未被找到
除了蔣忠義
警方在張大鵬手機裏。
發現的兇手還不止一人。
警方在張大鵬
與一位霓裳士
白天是上帝
晚上是惡魔的人
聊天就裏發現
2023年12月4日。
這個人
曾經跟張大鵬分享經驗說。
80%以上的女性。
在被強姦之後
什麼也不敢說
在這之後的一個月裏。
他又發給張大鵬說。
他每次性侵女性的時候。
都會拍下來
很多的照片和視頻。
嘻嘻
這些女性
雖然會哭著求我刪掉。
但是從來都不敢報警。
最後還推薦張大鵬。
在性侵時
帶著GoPro和手機。
以防性侵時疼不開手。
而他在用藥時
也會下十分過量的。
陣型雷藥物
在2024年8月。
他還跟張大鵬說
自己給一位女性
一次性就下了
六到七片三組輪
張大鵬感到驚艷的回覆說。
用了這麼多基礎
那你拍的清廷視頻呢？
他回答說
等我剪輯完了之後。
再發給你
隨著警方的進一步。
調查發現
這個人
就是周童
周童1999年生。
四川成都人
相貌普通
身高1米7
外表看上去
絲毫沒有攻擊性
2015年開始
15歲的周童
就來到了德國駐基礎學校。
但是因為學期不好。
就撤學回國
後來過了一段時間。
再次來到德國念本科。
幾年時間
不斷在德國
多個城市生活過
最終2022年9月。
定居柏林
也正因此
周童
將自己稱為
老柏林人
周童這個老柏林人。
經常會很熱情的
對待認識的女性
他說
他願意為他人
提供免費的
階級服務
當然
這個他
指的是女子旁的他。
他也會免費
幫女生寄村行李
他在朋友圈
以及社交軟件上
打造的人設就是暖男。
他生活規律
學校
圖書館
健身房
三點一線
愛好是騎行和露營。
最拿得出手的
是自己的廚藝
他也很喜歡下廚房。
在語言班的同學說。
班上
如果有女生不舒服。
周童
甚至還會主動
給他們煮雞湯
煮雞湯
甚至還被開玩笑的。
稱之為是中央空調。
但他時常也會
向其他人抱怨
就是說
為什麼像自己
這麼好的男人
到現在還找不到女朋友。
可是
他好嗎
他做這些的
出發點是什麼呢？
他真的是
這麼無私
這麼友善的一個人嗎。
小莎講述了
他和周童之間的
故事
小莎是在
2022年2月
柏林留學期間
認識的周童
當時的他在
飯局上
跟朋友
以及朋友的朋友
也就是周童
一起吃了飯
飯桌上的周童
表現的溫和
綿天
加上了小莎的
聯繫方式之後
周童就開始
對他虛寒溫暖起來。
他說自己是老柏林人。
對柏林很熟
可以帶著小莎
四處放鬆放鬆
但是當小莎
拒絕了他的邀請之後。
周童就輕易的破防了。
他說
你們文科
哪那麼難呀？
論文隨便寫寫都能過。
我學理工的
都沒你這麼忙
開始貶低了
對啊？
但當小莎
真問起他教的理工。
是什麼專業
什麼大學的時候
周童又開始
織織污污的
不敢明說
他們之間的
聊天便開始
冷淡下來
直到小莎
有了一個交換
生機會
他即將
去其他國家
進行交換
出發前
小莎想到
在德國租的房子
可以退
那在德國的行李呢？
總不能
也寄回中國吧？
有留學經驗的
朋友都知道
國際快遞油費
都不便宜
如果到時候
交換回來
再結束
返回德國
那幾大箱行李
又要從
中國寄回來
一來一回的
快遞費都
相當昂貴了
於是呢？
小莎就在
朋友圈裡
發一條求助消息
說
希望有在德國的
朋友
能夠幫助自己
寄存下行李
結果
首先表示
熱情幫助的人
就是有一段時間
沒有聯繫過的
周童
隨後
小莎也就把行李
寄存到了
周童的家裡
但誰能想到
周童似乎認為
就是某種訊號
在小莎交換的
這段期間
周童就一直
不斷的給小莎
發消息
開始沒話找話
但是那會
小莎已經有男朋友了。
也明確告訴了周童。
但周童呢？
依然還是
保持著這種
聊天方式
有一次
小莎放假
回德國
一段時間
周童就果斷的
提出
要來接機
在小莎拒絕之後
周童
還是自己私自
查了航班信息
帶著一隻玫瑰花
來到機場
讀小莎
說一定要
送她回家
小莎這個時候
就已經開始
感覺到害怕了
就趕緊從機場
逃回到了自己家
小莎
最後一次
跟周童接觸
就是交換
正式結束
回德國的時候
那不說不知道
周童一得知
小莎即將再次
返回德國之後
又是提出
自己可以接機
說可以帶著行李
接在機場
接小莎
然後連人帶行李
一起送到她家
小莎聽到這臉
想了想
如果是這樣
那應該還可以
避免了自己之後
獨自去周童家裡
取行李的情況
於是
在小莎抵達德國
下了飛機之後
就開始跟周童
準備開車回家
結果
這會周童就變掛了。
他說
自己
要去老闆那邊
繞一下
中間那段時間
可以讓小莎在車裡等著。
如果太累
太困的話
就先在車上睡一會。
聽到這
小莎就覺得
太麻煩了
拒絕了周童
然後
在後續聊天中
小莎就透露出
自己住的是多人宿舍。
周童立刻就說
讓小莎
自己做地鐵公交回去。
之後再把行李箱
單獨送到小莎家裡。
小莎就說
那洗豬用品
都在箱子裡
這怎麼辦呢？
周童又給出了一個建議。
就是
讓小莎
先到車上
把後背箱打開
把洗豬用品
單拿出來之後
自己
做地鐵公交回家
等到後面
周童再開車
把行李箱
送到小莎家裡
就是聽到小莎
不是一個人住
然後就不想送她了唄。
是的
小莎聽到這
就有點生氣了
答應的接機
一聽到住的多人宿舍。
就不送了
在這之後
小莎就從周童的車上。
拿了自己的行李箱。
自己回了家
相信
聽到這裡的朋友
應該都知道
周童在這次
接機流程裡
早就預備了
兩個迷間
小莎的地點
第一個
就是美其名曰
要去老闆那邊
逛一圈的地方
希望讓小莎
在車上等著
甚至建議她
在車上睡覺
那第二個
就是小莎的家裡
但是當得知
小莎有事有之後
也就放棄了
周童一直期望的
都是一個
只有兩個人的單獨空間。
一個能夠讓她完成下藥。
順利實施性侵的空間。
當這兩點
都不滿足的情況下。
周童就會迅速的
即時止損
中斷他的計劃
而周童的計劃
直到2026年
小莎通過朋友
轉發的新聞報告之後。
才反映過來
慶幸自己當初還好。
沒有跟著周童
上了他的車
但小莎
終究只是
糊口脫嫌的少數人。
正像周童
Telegram的網民。
後漫局一樣
白天去上帝
晚上是惡魔
警方順著
張大鵬的手機線索。
找到關於
周童的情報
越來越多
在2023年11月。
到2024年9月。
不到一年的時間裡。
周童跟張大鵬之間。
往來信息
就超過了兩千條
周童雖然年紀小
但卻反過來
經常給
張大鵬傳授
迷煎
以及慶親的建議
他說
要想如何
更好地避免
被女生發現
那就是
在家裡準備一套
和酒店
同款的
白色床單
讓受害者
不知道
自己在哪裡被慶親的。
他還說
自己在偷拍完
慶親視頻以後
不會立刻
拿出來給
受害者看
而是會偷偷的存起來。
放個一兩年
再拿出來
威脅受害者
此外
根據這些
聊天內容
周童
至少慶親了
十八位女性
她最喜歡女性
在被麻醉的
狀態下反抗
她們越反抗
周童
就會越興奮
她們哭得越慘
周童
就會覺得
越刺激
在2024年
12月13日
警方最後
將周童
捉拿歸案
當時的周童
十年
僅僅24歲
警方在
她的家裡
找到了大量的
震驚類藥物
女性內衣
注射器
上頭
以及她曾錄下的
超過量
TB內容的
慶親視頻
在她的電腦上
她記錄下來了
所有她慶親
或者是發生過
關係的女性
並且以這些
女性的名字命名
每個人都單獨
建立了
一個對應的文件夾。
在這些文件夾裡
都放著她
偷拍下來的視頻內容。
結合這些視頻內容。
以及周童的共述
警方得知
周童
第一次犯案
早在2019年
開始
當時的她
強姦了自己的女朋友。
並且用手機
拍下了視頻
還在鄰居
以及自己的家裡的浴室。
裝上了隱藏攝像頭。
偷拍鄰居
以及室友
洗澡和上廁所的畫面。
而她一直說的
喜歡露營
她也以同樣的手段。
多次偷拍下了
多個一起
旅行的女性旅遊
洗澡時的視頻
這裡注意
我在講述的時候
可能只有一兩句話。
但事實上
這個安裝隱藏攝像頭。
或者是用手機
偷拍的手段
周童持續了好幾年。
受害者
包括周童身邊的
幾乎一切女性
同事以及好朋友
和鄰居
此外
她甚至還在
2024年7月20日。
沒見了一位
具有輕度身體
和智力
精神障礙的女性
周童在社交軟體上。
把她約出來
在午晚餐的酒粒
倒入了高級量的安眠藥。
導致她陷入了
重度昏迷
失去意識的狀態
隨後對她實施了信心。
並且拍攝了視頻
直到一位女性警察。
通過給她播放
當時的視頻和照片之後。
她才意識到發生了什麼。
然而這也對她造成了。
相當程度的恐懼
以及精神創傷
在這之後的幾個禮拜裡。
她甚至都不敢
跟男性共處
在同一個空間內
也不敢睡覺
她開始害怕黑夜
在周童的停止上
她最終還是沒有出庭作證。
停止現場
周童成為了
與張大鵬有關的
所有案件中
被檢方起訴的
年紀最小的人
2025年8月
柏林地方法院認定。
周童犯有包括
強姦及侵犯
個人隱私等13項罪名。
涉及至少9名受害酒。
雖然法院在判決中。
嚴重批判周童的犯罪行為。
具有令人
發指的業女傾向
且基於德國刑法典。
第46條第二款中。
要將基於性別
和針對性侷向的犯罪動機。
列為加重處罰
情節因素
也就是說
如果加害者是
出於對女性的仇恨。
清滅
支配欲
實施謀殺
傷害
恐嚇
性暴力
或者網絡暴力的
法官在
最後量刑的時候
應該把這種動機
納入考量
並且可以作為
從重處罰的理由
但最終
因為周童在
第一次犯罪時
年紀較小
只判處
5年
09個月有期徒刑。
且沒有
預防性羈押措施
截至到目前
檢方還沒有
重新提起上訴
不知道
在未來
如我重新上訴的
情況下
判決
是否還會加重
後續對
張大鵬
Telegram的群組。
發現
其實這裡
並不都是位於
德國的
性犯罪者
其中最核心的
德國老司機
還有群中
根據他的
發現內容推測
這個人
似乎是一位
南加州
大學的
博士研究生
2025年1月
德國聯邦
協調海局
向洛杉磯市警察局。
發出情報通報
指認了一名
曾在德國活動的
群組成員
而他的名字
就是
翁思哲
1995年生人
從
中國南州大學
理論物理系畢業後。
2018年
就進入了
南加州大學
公讀碩士
從2021年
開始在
南加州大學
為特別工程學院
讀博
主修的是
電子工程
並且還兼任助教
負責主持
超過50名
來自
不同專業
和背景的
研究生
與本科生的
討論課
作業輔導
和考試
複習課
那他平時肯定很容易。
接觸到各種各樣的。
學生啊？
是的
農場機警察局
副局長
跟你有一樣的
想法
他在調查到
這些時候
立刻就意識到
如果他擔任過助教。
那出於職業關係
可能還會有
更多的
潛在受害者
那在警方這邊
目前
已知的受害者
是有三名
第一位
是翁思哲的
女性發小
小兵
出於對翁思哲的信任。
在2021年
12月
小兵
答應了和翁思哲
一起去
生第二個旅遊
但他不知道的是
翁思哲很早
就通過了
德國性侵群組
買到了
各類迷藥
在他的心裏
這一趟
所謂的旅行
其實
就是一趟
性侵之旅
在白天
疲憊的旅遊結束後。
翁思哲和小兵
就去到了
一家酒吧裏面
放鬆休息
趁著小兵
不注意的時候
翁思哲就把迷藥
倒進了
小兵的酒裏
小兵喝完之後
就開始覺得
有些恍惚
提出說
想回酒店休息
但是
當他們
喝完的時候
小兵已經是
進呼到了
昏睡的狀態
於是
翁思哲
開始取求
另一種藥物
注射到了
小兵的體裏
同時也用了
第三種藥物
捂住了小兵的嘴
這就是
翁思哲
從群島裏面
學到的迷藥三件套。
他利用了
小兵從小
一起長大對他的信任。
讓小兵
成為了
他的第一個實驗品。
在這裏
翁思哲開始擴大
他的目標範圍
通過機場
階級的方式
瀰漸了
第二位受害者
並且在
2023年到2024年。
對他的同一位
博士班級裏的女同學。
三次實施下藥清清。
雖然受害者在睡醒後。
發現自己
極度的頭暈和濕水。
但他並不知道
具體發生了什麽
直到2025年
8月28日
洛杉磯警方
才正式
把翁思哲逮捕
在翁思哲的家裏
警方收到了
大量的
性侵視頻內容
大量的隱隱嘗試攝像頭。
性侵時所使用的
作案工具
以及藥物注射器
等相關的醫療器器。
被捕之後的
翁思哲
為了爭取良好表現。
就像警方
事無具體的講述了。
他是如何
性侵著
三位受害者的經過。
但警方認為
真正的數字
只可能比這個
更多
一方面是因為
翁思哲特殊的
職業關係
另一方面也是
因為翁思哲
一直是在
如果不是
德國警方提供
線索
他們可能一輩子
也發現不了
翁思哲的罪行
那值得一提的是
你這裏看
感覺翁思哲
比較老是吧？
但當他在
牢房裏警方
不在的時候
有調查員
就聽到
牢房裏的
錄音設備裏面
傳來
翁思哲說
如果能
獲得保釋的話
就會立刻逃回
中國
因為中國跟
美國之間
沒有引渡條約
所以
認為
翁思哲
存在高度的
遣逃風險
實際上
就算沒有
監聽到翁思哲
說這句話
他有沒有可能
獲得保釋呢？
我推測
可能也沒有
因為他的
案情性質
實在是
太惡劣了
在
洛杉磯檢方
9月2日
起訴
翁思哲的內容中
其中
包含了
八項
重罪指控
涉及到
以藥物
或者麻醉手段
罪名罪行
如果裴審團
認定這些罪名
成立
向前面提到的
美國加州
實行的邏輯
每項罪名
獨立計算
並且
刑期疊加
翁思哲
最高
會面臨
25年
至終身監禁
且
被追加
56年刑期
同時
會將翁思哲
終身登記
為刑罪犯
那截止到目前
因為在
初次庭人中
翁思哲
已經正式提出
都不認罪的
抗辯
原定於
2026年1月14日。
進行的
預審聽證會的排氣。
也因為
當天
壓解翁思哲時
交通出現
特殊狀況
不得不順眼排氣
所以
目前翁思哲
依然還沒有
進入正式的
預審聽證會
也更沒有
進入到
裴審團審判環節
理論上
翁思哲
仍然是
一個被告人
而不是
已經被定罪的犯人。
洛杉基檢察長
在宣布起訴的時候。
不斷的
呼籲潛在的
說話者出面
還在記者會上
展示了
翁思哲的照片
並提供了
洛杉基警察局的
聯繫方式
他們如此迫切
目的只有一個
就是要確保翁思哲。
為他的行為
付出代價
既然說到付出代價。
其實目前
此時此刻
已經付出代價的人。
案件中
涉及到的
刑犯罪者
目前最多
也就是
聽證結束
認罪
最多不到3年
對比起他們
所犯下的罪行來說。
還遠遠
撐不上
算是付出代價
唯有一位
是已經徹底為此
付出死亡代價的
許許開源
和周童一樣
1999年生人
年齡也比較小
其實在
2024年
11月14日
逮捕完張大鵬之後。
最早鎖定的人員名單裏面。
就有位於
德國漢堡的
許許開源
在逮捕張大鵬之後的。
兩周左右
2024年12月初。
警方就逮捕了
許許開源
但沒有過多長時間。
12月13日
許許開源
就在被羈押的期間。
為罪自殺了
也因此
德國警方
不得不終止
所有針對
許許開源的
刑事追溯
以及司法調查
所以我們在這裏
只能根據
維持不多的信息
勉強拼湊出
他的形象
在他的朋友圈子裏。
一位女性朋友說
許許開源這個人
人緣很好
經常出入各種聚會裏。
很多朋友誇他
誇什麽呢？
說他特別有同理心。
特別尊重女性
是男性裏面
少有的能夠做到
真正共情女性的代表。
許許開源
從來不在公共場合。
對女生動手動腳
也不會像
大多數男生那樣
滿嘴的黃色笑話
有女朋友的時候
走哪都會
帶著女朋友一起
還會主動跟
其他異性保持距離。
他還說
自己一直在戀愛中受傷。
羨慕那些玩得很開的男性。
還額外的感慨自己。
做不到
但另壹面
他在德國漢堡的壹家。
跨境物流
與供應鏈管理公司工作。
擔任的是物流經理。
同時還任職於
壹家生物醫藥公司。
網傳
再自殺前
許許開源還反覆
盯住了自己的律師。
讓他
不要透露
任何國內的貨源
以及相關供應鏈條。
那我們根據這些也能想到了。
他在這個群組中
處於壹個什麽地位。
他就是幫助這些
所謂的
迷藥三年套
從國內運輸到德國。
再分發到各個國家。
以及城市的核心成員。
正是因為有了他的幫助。
那些懦弱的幻想
才得以實現
此外
還有網傳信息顯示。
許許開源不僅幫助迷藥運輸。
同時也效仿
張大棚的作案方式。
在社交軟件上假裝女性。
編造各種旅遊約見面。
隨後實施下藥
以及迷監行為
涉及到的受害者至少有五位。
其中包括在德國的留學生。
也有已經開始在德國。
工作的華人女性
那出於律師的保密義務。
許許開源的律師無法。
將相關犯罪鏈條
透露給警方
以及檢察院
所以
許許開源的跨境
維京藥品走私鏈條。
至今還未被徹底發現。
而在另一條疑似時。
telegram。
迷監群組中的兩層記錄顯示。
當群組中的其他人。
得知許許開源
做出自殺行為之後。
紛紛稱讚他
有情有意
根據警方對德國老司一家。
和群組的調查
目前還有兩位成員。
尚未被發現
現有的調查進展中。
另外一名和性成員。
還在走司法程序當中。
那就是
利用自己在医藥方面的。
相關知識
不斷為其他成員
提供專業擁有建議的。
邵之廷
根據警方調查出的信息顯示。
邵之廷最早在2024年1月。
加入了這個和性的。
八人群組當中
那個時候
張大鵬在群裡給
其他七位群友
直播迷見一位女性。
並沒有成功
隨後邵之廷給了一個建議。
他說
你餵他兩片藥
他就不會記得任何事情。
並且在第二天
邵之廷還不忘
再次在群裡詳細講述。
如何下藥
以及如何迷見等等。
相關的操作技巧
隨後在邵之廷
講解後的第二天
張大鵬再次對女性。
實施犯罪
並在群組內進行直播。
當蔣仲義在群內
群們擁有建議的時候。
跳出來的
也是邵之廷
他問的是
車有多重
蔣仲義回答53公斤。
隨後
邵之廷就給蔣仲義。
提供了詳細的擁有建議。
蔣仲義也得以對
受害者實施行徑
聽到這裡
你的腦海裡
可能會有一個神秘的形象。
一個只是躲在手機背後。
不斷被受害者
提供建議的神秘人。
但實際上
關於邵之廷
所犯下的罪行
還遠遠不知於此
邵之廷1993年生。
江蘇江英世人
他一家人
全部都是
虔誠的佛教徒
家裡也是長年放著佛經。
每日燒香拜佛
經常去放生
公開信心裡
甚至還能查到
邵之廷的放生記錄。
根據邵之廷的朋友說。
他是從小
就立下了一個志向。
那就是
要研究治療癌症的特效藥。
於是
從初中開始
就決心
攻堵醫學方向
本科就考入了
河北一科大學
期間發表的一篇論文。
還獲得了
河北省
傑出青年
科學基金的資助
隨後
考入了北京大學
總留醫院
盛哀
黑色素流科
攻堵碩士
截至到現在
還能收到很多
邵之廷
在北大獨研期間
參與撰寫的學術論文。
2021年秋
邵之廷來到德國柏林。
進入夏裏特醫院
攻堵醫學博士學位。
研究方向
是
清洗性癌細胞
邵之廷
所救出的醫學院
同樣也是
歐洲最大的
大學附屬教學醫院。
它就像
各種小說裏面的
模範主人工一樣
從始至終
潛心朝著
一個方向努力著
然而
在2024年12月。
隨著對
張大鵬
手機中
群聊信息的調查
警方
很快便鎖定了
邵之廷
並且讓他逮捕
雖然看群消息
邵之廷
是在2024年
1月
才加入了這個群組當中的。
但是警方
卻在他的郵件裏
翻到了更早
他為其他人
提供性犯罪
建議的證據
2022年9月
邵之廷的郵箱裏
就收到了
這麼一封郵件
內容是
你好
請問如何稱呼您
隨後
發見人開始
詳細地描述
他即將進行
犯罪的對象
他說
這個女生
剛來德國獨博不久。
德語不好
思想也很保守
並且還是處女
諸如此類的信息
在邵之廷
給他提供完
民間建議之後
對方表示
感謝邵之廷
友好的指導
但從內容上
我們可以得出
這麼一個信息
就是他說自己
從2024年1月。
才加入到這個群組。
也就是那個時候
才開始
為他人提供
犯罪建議
那怎麼解釋
這封郵件呢？
一封來路
不明的郵件
是在什麼樣的
情況下
都不知道邵之廷
叫什麼
就知道他是
民間的老手
並且能夠成為
傳授建議
以及被諮詢的對象呢？
也就是說
其實邵之廷
在2022年9月。
甚至更早的時間
就已經開始熟練的。
進行民間行為
並且在
民間交流網絡圈子裏面。
分享經驗
成為了一個
小有名氣的
信犯罪者了
而警方在邵之廷家裏。
搜尋到了大量的
信息兒童的視頻內容。
此外還發現
邵之廷最早於
2019年7月
到2021年7月。
就在中國
多次性侵過一位女性。
至少5次
其中
甚至還有時事
火通他人
一起進行犯罪的
而如果你把這個時間。
和她求學經歷
對比起來看
就會發現
這是邵之廷
還在北大
獨延期間
所犯下的
多次民間罪行
而這5次
民間行為的受害者。
則是邵之廷
目前的
未婚妻
2024年12月。
邵之廷
第一次被捕
為什麼我說第一次呢？
因為2025年
他被保釋出來過
保釋出來幹嘛？
他去寫博士論文
並且在2025年5月份。
提交了博士論文
在9月15日
還通過了博士答辯。
答辯結束後的兩天。
才再次被
德林法官
簽發的代補令
收押
從代補
直到2026年3月19日。
柏林地方法院
才對邵之廷
所犯下的案件
第一次正式開庭審理。
邵之廷帶著口罩
走進法庭
並且向旁聽席的人們。
揮手示意
在這期中
有不少
為了觀看邵之廷
受審的女性
她被指控
犯有協助
特別嚴重性質的
強姦罪
協助危害身體罪
以及持有
兒童色情內容罪
最嚴重的
就是邵之廷
在19年到21年。
在中國持續對
未婚妻
實施的多次強姦
因為德國刑法裏面。
有一條
就是對於在
德國境內
被發現的
犯罪嫌疑人
德國法院
可以對他
使用
境外
犯罪管轄權
而邵之廷
則在辯護時
針對此項罪名
則以德國法院
對在
中國境內的行為
無管轄權為由
正在做
無罪辯護
除此之外
邵之廷也是這幾位。
犯罪者
在庭審上
最狡猾
和無賴的人之一
儘管已經以
博士生的身份
在德國生活了五年。
在庭審現場
他依然
堅持向
法官表示
自己
不會得獄
需要通過
中德翻譯
來為他
進行
實施互議
而且
邵之廷
與代理律師
還多次打斷庭審
對法庭上
出事的資料
提出質疑
理由裏面就包括
翻譯部隊
而在
2026年5月4日。
在針對
邵之廷
第二次庭審的
旁聽席上
有幾位
中國女性到場
其中有一位
帶了幾張
只和一盒
水彩筆
在開庭過程中
他用紅色
水彩筆不斷寫下
中國男性
有辱國格
另外幾位女性
同樣也
畫下了
邵之廷的塑血
邵之廷
則是縮在了
最高席雨
牆壁的夾腳之間
情緒平靜
沒有太大的波動
為他辯護的兩名律師。
均為
非亞裔的
中年至中老年男性。
5月18日
是邵之廷案
第五次庭審
在柏林州法院
出現了大量的
華人面孔
有人從早上
8點就來排隊
有人從
法蘭克福等
其他城市趕來
還有40個人
只能站在
門外等候
其中大部分
都是中國女性
他們擠滿了樓道
其中一位女性
對來到這裡的記者說。
我們現在過來
就是為了讓她感受到。
我們都在看著她
但唯一警方
最希望出現在這裡的。
也是原定出席的
邵之廷在中國北京。
犯下5次
迷姦案的受害者
她的未婚妻
沒有出現
她行使了
德國行事自動法中的。
親屬拒絕作證權
表示
不會出庭提供證言。
而這項指控
也是針對邵之廷案件中。
所犯下的罪行中
最嚴重的指控
唯一的證人拒絕作證。
檢方就會失去
重要的證據來源
但實在無法勉強
法院必須尊重她的選擇。
庭審過程中
邵之廷坐在
仿報玻璃隔間內
戴著藍色的異用口罩。
頭髮被剃得很短
全程灌注著
聽著每個人的發言。
當翻譯跟她講話時。
她會微微點頭
當律師發問時
她會微微前傾
她幾乎不會看上
旁聽席
她神太自若
縱然旁聽席上
有幾乎
全部的女性注視著她。
她也依然
無動於衷
未敢羞愧
甚至
沒能讓她
做出任何明顯的反應。
截止目前
邵之廷的醫審
還尚未審理完畢
下一次的開庭日期。
是6月2日
可能是我們發布
節目後的第2天
整個醫審的判決結果。
最早可能也要到
6月底我們才能知道。
好 以上
差不多就是我們
本期節目中的
所有罪案部分相關內容。
由於涉及
八名性犯罪者
受限於篇幅
以及目前的調查進展。
我們無法
全部列舉他們
當下的每一樁罪行。
只能希望通過講述。
他們在犯罪時
常用的作案手法
來幫助大家在生活中。
警醒周圍類似的
性犯罪者
在本期節目中
小燕 小雪 小葉。
小影 小花 小子。
小藍 小冰 小沙。
均為化名
其餘出現的姓名中。
周正豪 徐超
張大棚 蔣中毅
周童 翁思哲
徐徐 開源 邵志廷。
均為根據目前調查進展。
及媒體報道中
出現的真實姓名
在講述的內容裏
為了防止模仿犯罪。
也為了防止
可以利用罪案內容。
來引起性欲
也引去了
在這幾位的犯罪行為中。
關於性侵經過的細節描寫。
本期節目的尾聲最後。
我們想問的是
我們現在
到底生活在一個
什麼樣的社會裏
案件中出現的個例。
難道只是偶然嗎
那剩下的那些
遍布歐洲各國
幾千位中國男性群友。
又叫做什麼呢？
他們可能會說
他們又沒有犯罪
難道只是在群裏看消息。
看他們分享出來的。
性侵視頻
也犯法
說實話
這個問題
還真的暫時沒有辦法解答。
我們只知道的是
這些人到目前為止。
還沒有得到
任何的懲罰
我甚至問過
身邊的女性朋友說。
如果你發現你的伴侶。
在這種群聊中
只是看著
不說話
也沒有犯罪
你會怎麼做呢？
他給我的回答是
那還能怎麼樣
總不能因為這個分手吧？
我想
如果我們對身邊的。
每一個人都這麼寬容。
那他們最終
又會變成什麼樣子的人呢？
或許就像
講中意和宣判時
竹孫法官馬克思
克鵬萊特納說的
我們正在探討一片。
全新的法律領域
這些行為極其嚴重。
極其專業
並且蔑視人性和女性。
他們之所以面對
如此性質的惡劣
還審理了這麼久
被迫一再反覆的
回顧
作案的視頻
正是因為缺乏
聯邦最高法院的指導意見。
也沒有任何
參審法庭
曾經審理過此類案件。
面對因為互聯網
極速演變的
另一種新型的犯罪的。
新暴力
不光法律
我們自己
本身也缺失了
識別惡的邊界的能力。
我們自己也不知道。
應該以什麼樣的態度。
來去對待這種情況。
來去對待
參加了此類事件的群組成員。
而德國內閣
也意識到了
同樣的問題
在2026年5月。
他們通過了
新的草案
計劃將使用
迷肩
強姦的最低刑期
從3年提至5年
針對這系列案件的審理。
也將成為日後對待。
審理此類型案件的。
重要參考
既然德國法律
面對這種問題後
開始有了改變
我們普通人
是不是也需要
從當下進行改變呢？
其實不光是Telegram。
很多中國的社交軟件。
也是迷肩群組的
重要交流平台
我希望
如果我們在群僚中看到。
或者是發現了
有人分享了
明顯屬於偷拍女性的。
圖像及視頻內容
我們起碼能夠做到舉報。
並且在群僚中警告和制止。
我想可能女性
挺有所在的群組中。
很少有這種情況
但不知道怎麼回事。
一旦一個群組中
幾乎是男性
那就很容易出現
有這種偷拍
分享
或者是傳播色情內容的信息。
所以有些話
我想對男性的
聽我們說
如果你發現這種情況。
但你沒有做
任何形式的制止
警告以及舉報
反而是默默的觀看。
甚至分享
再次傳播
那我覺得
你也成為了
性犯罪的幫凶者之一。
其次
除了群僚和社交軟件。
我希望
大家在色情網站上。
也不要觀看
任何形式的
被社者女性
明顯不知情
且不同意的
圖像以及影片
並且一件舉報
在2020年12月。
全球主要信用卡
及支付巨頭
Visa和萬世達。
在確認了Penghub存在。
違法內容之後
就宣布了
無限期終止
為Penghub集齊母公司。
Mandgake旗下的。
所有成人平台
提供現金流和支付服務。
Penghub也是從那開始。
一夜之間下架了
超過一千萬部
涉及大量
未成年人
真實強姦
偷拍
虐待
以及未經當事人同意。
而被惡意傳播的
復仇式的色情影片。
在這之後
Penghub也徹底改變了。
過去類似於
YouTube上。
允許所有用戶
自由上傳的運作模式。
而推行了
更加嚴格的限制
比方說
禁止
未認證的用戶上傳。
禁止視頻的下載
以及更加嚴格的深刻。
因為
如果你觀看
類似的視頻
那每一次的播放和傳播。
都會構成
對影片內
女性的性剝削和傷害。
那既然都說到這裡了。
我也建議大家最好。
不要觀看
存在煉銅
迷姦
強姦
等違法的
性暴力題材的AV影片。
我理解
影片內的內容
都不是真實的
是演藝的
但根據我
淺薄的認知和理解。
我覺得
一個人
長期的觀看
此類型題材的影片。
是會助長這種
不正確的性觀念的。
在兩年前
BBC的紀錄片
追查吃汗裏面
記者臥底到
偷拍網站背後的
放對團伍當中
他們的老闆就提到。
人一開始
可能只是不正確的性觀念。
通過觀看
演藝的AV來滿足。
但慢慢的
這個預直
會被拉高
最終導致
他們追求
更加真實的
更加刺激的體驗
他們就會成為那種。
開始觀看
真實的
偷拍
以及性侵視頻的人。
最後
他們甚至也會成為。
偷拍以及
性侵他人的
犯罪者之一
所以我在這裏
必須強調
這種現象
是真實存在的
迷間群組中的
4000多人
每一位都是
潛在的
性犯罪者
事實上
就在我們
今天講述的
BBC案件中
其中就包含
多個類似
這種性犯罪者
比如說
張大鵬
他在青少年時期
就因為偷偷看了
父親的
強姦主題的色情視頻。
因而產生了
迷間女性的想法
這種性幻想
非但沒有得到
及時的糾正
直到2020年
張大鵬在
色情網站上
看到了
真實的
被下藥的女性
遭受
強姦的使命後
他就
當即
立刻決定
要把自己的幻想
付諸於現實
同時
進入了
Telegram的。
第一個
迷間群組
也在
同年8月
購買了
四種迷間藥物
在這裏後的
不到5個月
2021年1月
就開始了
他的
第一次犯罪
大家注意
張大鵬的這個
時間進展
是相當迅速的
我理解
每個人的
性批
可能都不一樣
但有一些性批
我雖然不太想
太決斷的
下定義
但以我的理解
他的存在
本身
可能就是錯誤的
這些
非正常的
性批背後
折射出的是
兩個人
在權力之間
的不平等
是一方
嚴重的剝削
是一個個體
對另外一個個體
極度的仇恨
以及物化
很多時候
這種題材的
色情作品
其實展示的
並不是
兩個成年人之間
如何平等的
有情感的流動
而是具有暴力性
和侵害性的內容
而我們
應該在這方面
樹立
正確的
新觀念
盡早的認識到
自己心批方面的
問題
就可以盡早的
進行糾正
避免自己
成為一位
現在的
性犯罪者
說到這裡
又想到了
我們在
新教育方面的缺失。
就連最基本的
性同意
相關的內容
都沒有
性同意
意味著對
身體自主權的
絕對尊重
而身體自主權
是一項
最基本的人權
意味著
我的身體
只有我
自己
說了算
無論雙方是
情侶
夫妻
還是結婚了
幾十年的伴侶
任何人都
沒有對
身體的
永久使用權
他們之間的
每一次
親密接觸
都需要
經過獨立的
性同意
而真正的
必須滿足
五個條件
第一
雙方必須
是處於
完全自願的
任何因為害怕
為了討好對方
或者是
威脅下的
服從
都是不同意
第二
性同意
也可以是
隨時撤回的
就算性行為
已經開始
只要
必須
都必須立刻停止
第三
雙方必須
是對性行為的
任何細節
完全知情的
比如在
進行到一半時
如果南方
偷偷摘掉安全套
這是
與方的
性同意
就會被視為失效
第四
性同意
必須是
積極
熱情
且主動的
真正的
性同意
是表示給你
一個
明確的信號
而不是
消極的
充滿
沒有說
拒絕
不代表
他同意了
這次性行為
第五
也是最核心的
一點
雙方必須是
處於
完全清醒
狀態下的
任何處於
醉酒
沉睡
或者是
昏迷下的人
都是
不具備
性同意的
能力的
此時此刻
對他的
任何
性觸碰
都是
強姦
在
2025年
的行為
剝奪了
受害者的
性同意能力
性質
極其惡劣
而事實上
不光在
瘟死者的
案件中
我們今天
所講述的
每一個
案件裡
涉及到的
每一位
女性受害者
他們在
案發的時候
都處在
被下藥的
深度
昏迷
甚至是
冰淋死亡的狀態
他們無一例外
全部被
性犯罪者
剝奪了
機會
被他們
剝奪了
最基本的人權
也是因此
我們想在這裡
此時此刻
挺內視的他們
像那些
懦弱
卑鄙的
性犯罪者說
我不同意
案件的最後
想要給大家分享的是。
11 Long Years。
這是一位
小數的女性博主
根據此次
中國留學生
連環性性的
主要內容
寫的歌詞
製作的音樂
第一次聽到以後
我就覺得
非常有力量
連著聽了好幾遍
並且通過私信
申請了放在
我們本期節目的最後。
給大家聽
也十分感謝這位
小紅書博主
尼采雷歐的幫助
希望大家喜歡
也十分感謝
針對這系列案件中。
持續不斷在
中國報導的
各種媒體
記者
以及自媒體人
我們下期再見
拜拜